pour la dixième édition de la fête de la
nature le département ouvre ses sites
des espaces naturels sensibles au public
il organise tout un programme autour de
la thématique passionné par nature et
met en lumière les hommes et les femmes
qui oeuvrent au quotidien sur ses
différents sites à travers plusieurs
actions alors déjà du jeudi 12 au lundi
nous avons 19 sites ouverts sur
l'ensemble du territoire
au total une cinquantaine de visites des
visites allant d'une visite guidée à une
rencontre des hommes sur le terrain à
l'équithérapie à des prestations de
découverte des plantes de
l'aromathérapie aussi des déjeuners
sympathique mais aussi des récits des
jeux de pistes de connaissance ou encore
de réflexion comme le propose le site de
l'association capitaine dimitile située
à 1800 mètres d'altitude à l'antre-2 on
a demandé à chaque participant déjà de
venir avec eux un objet une photo
quelque chose qui pourrait avoir un lien
pour eux avec la nature et une fois
arrivés sur le site là haut on va aller
s'engager dans un jeu de rallye base
voilà avec deux bases une base dédiée
avec la connaissance de l'environnement
donc de tous ces plantes endémiques et
indigènes qu'on peut trouver sur le site
et une base ceux d'histoire et après
donc ce jeu on va demander à chacun
justement par rapport à l'ofce qui
seront emmenés de nous dire pour eux
qu'un lien ça peut avoir la nature
principal propriétaire forestière de
lille la collectivité départementale met
en oeuvre une gestion durable de son
patrimoine naturel
elle protège les milieux et paysages
exceptionnels tout en assurant leur
valorisation
l'aménagement et l'ouverture à tous les
publics l'ouvrier lui va aménager
sécurisé et entretenir donc que tous les
sentiers donc qui qui parcourt du
parcours lille
arthur particulièrement les jeunes est
ce donc et aussi ce qu'il dira
restauration écologique donc une
activité plus vocation conservatoire
donc on a des trésors de biodiversité
qu'il faut conserver valoriser donc on
l'enlève
on essaie de contrôler les exotiques
envahissantes pour replanter des espèces
indigènes donc associé à ça une activité
pépinière tout est dit tout est dit on
compte retient aménagements activités
conservatoire restauration écologique
c'est le panel d'activités qu'on peut
faire sur un espace la collectivité
départementale investit chaque année 10
millions d'euros pour la préservation et
l'aménagement de plus de cent mille
hectares de milieux naturels
la thématique de cette année permet au
public de découvrir la diversité des
métiers qui oeuvrent dans ces différents
milieux à travers des temps de partage
des rencontres et des témoignages
c'est vrai que ça permet de de maillé un
petit peu si vous voulez nature
développement économique touristique est
aussi sociale parce que nous avons des
jeunes qui travaillent en insertion sur
ces espaces et qui donne un côté donc
très économique et très comment vous
dire c'est qu'on développe la réunion à
travers différents outils et la nature
en est un un très important et c'est
vrai qu'au département nous avons cette
vocation là qui nous porte justement à
coeur parce que nous voulons que les
réunionnais découvrent leur nature en
travaillant en s'investissant et en
montrant à l'ensemble des réunionnais ce
qu'ils sont capables de faire sur ces
territoires
en plus de valoriser et préserver notre
patrimoine naturel
cet événement a pour objectif de
sensibiliser le public aux enjeux de la
protection de la biodiversité à partager
un moment privilégié et convivial au
coeur d'un patrimoine naturel unique